>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY DO PEOPLE WANT TO HELP
PRISONERS, LIKE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THERE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT'S ALL
ABOUT?
>> HAVE YOU SEEN THE PICTURE OF
THIS WOMAN?
>> NO.
>> I THINK SHE GOT TURNED OUT BY
THESE BAD BOYS.
>> DO YOU THINK SO?
>> YEAH, I DEFINITELY THINK SO.
AND APPARENTLY THIS GUY IS
PACKING SOME JUNK.
HE HAS PRISON GAME, TOO.
HE'S PROBABLY WHISPERING SWEET
NOTHINGS IN HER EAR.
ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS WORK ON
YOUR BODY IN PRISON.
>> IF THAT'S THE CASE, THE JUNK
IS LEAVING.
>> MAYBE HE PROMISED SHE WOULD
BE ALONG FOR THE RIDE, AND HE
LEFT HER.
YOU KNOW HOW YOU GUYS ARE.
>> IN THE DESCRIPTION, WHEN WAS
IT, LIKE, HE'S 6'0" TALL, WHITE,
HAS A BIG [BLEEP].
WHY IS THAT A THING?
WAS THERE A SKETCH ARTIST?
WAS I GOING TO FIND HIM IN
SWEATPANTS, AND BE, LIKE, I SEE
HIM, HE'S RUNNING THROUGH MY
NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT NOW.
>> MAYBE THERE WERE NO POWER
TOOLS.
MAYBE IT WAS JUST HIS [BLEEP].
>> OH, WOW!
YES.
THAT'S WHAT TIM ROBINS USED IN
"SHAWSHANK REDEMPTION," TOO.
>> TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
WHY WE'RE FASCINATED WITH THEM,
THE AMERICAN CRIMINAL IS
SOMETHING WE SEE ON TV, IN
MOVIES.
WHEN I WENT IN THERE, I SAW THAT
THEY WERE, LIKE, REGULAR GUYS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S DIRTBAGS. 90%
OF THE PEOPLE I PERFORM FOR IN
JAIL  ARE COMING OUT
ONE DAY.
THEY'RE OUR NEIGHBORS, OUR
FUTURE NEIGHBORS.
>> WHERE DO YOU LIVE?
>> IN NEW YORK CITY.
IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> DUDE, COME ON, THEY'RE
CRIMINALS.
>> ALLEGED CRIMINALS.
>> WAIT.
YOU THINK MOST OF THEM SHOULDN'T
BE THERE?
>> I FEEL LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE -- THIS IS CRAZY.
ONE IN EVERY HUNDRED AMERICANS
IS BEHIND BARS RIGHT NOW.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO IT'S US.
>> I DON'T FEEL BAD FOR THESE
GUYS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE OUT.
THEY'RE HAVING THE BEST WEEK OF
THEIR LIVES.
THEY GOT OUT OF JAIL AND ON
NATIONAL TV, THEY HAVE THE
BIGGEST [BLEEP]  OF ALL TIME.
I CAN'T FEEL BAD FOR THEM.
>> AS A CULTURE, WE ROMANTICIZE
THE NOTION OF THE CRIMINAL AND
OUTLAW.
EVEN OUR HIT SHOWS, TONY
SOPRANO, TONY MONTANA, DEXTER IS
A SERIAL KILLER THAT KILLS
SERIAL KILLERS.
"BREAKING BAD," A CRYSTAL METH
DEALER, A CHEMISTRY TEACHER,
FUNDING HIS KEMOTHERAPY.
I MEAN, HELLO.
THESE ARE OUR ANTIHEROES. DON
DRAPER.
WE LIKE THESE LARGER THAN LIFE
FLAWED CHARACTERS
>> YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WHY
SHE WENT FOR HIM.
THE FUNNY THING IS THE BIG
[BLEEP], WHATEVER.
SERIOUSLY, WHAT IS IT ABOUT
WOMEN AND BAD BOYS?
>> THEY'RE INCREDIBLY
CHARISMATIC.
YOU LIKE THE IDEA OF BEING ABLE
TO FLOUT, MAYBE REPRESS --
>> REMEMBER THAT GIRL WHO ALMOST
MARRIED CHARLES MANSON?
AND HE EVEN SAID THIS
IS A LITTLE CRAZY.
HE BROKE IT UP, RIGHT?
>> HE KNEW IT WAS CRAZY.
>> IT'S A CONTROLLING
RELATIONSHIP.
SHE WANTS TO KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
AT ALL TIMES.
>> THAT'S HILARIOUS.
>> WHERE ARE YOU?
>> I'M IN JAIL.
I GOT 25-LIFE, BITCH,
CALM DOWN!
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WONDER WHY
CHARLES MANSON'S FIANCEE BROKE
UP WITH HIM.
I'M GUESSING SHE GOOGLED HIM.
OH, YOU'RE THAT CHARLES MANSON.
>> BIGGEST SURPRISE EVER.